good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Tuesday hope
everybody's having an amazing week thus
far chugging along slowly but surely and
speaking of surely swirly girly it's Jax
surely twirly
you know a lot of people love Shirley
Temple me I'm more of a swirly Temple oh
well ain't that the truth she's the
modern day Shirley
she's the modern day woman she is
speaking of the modern day woman I saw
barbie yesterday I know where do you
want to place your recap because that's
really what we're here to hear
how about right here right now oh wow
you want to Dive Right In
I mean I've thought of nothing nothing
but because like I literally just
watch the movie Saw so many tick tocks
about it like kind of a divided country
we are on Barbie A lot of people did not
like it but it's also bringing people
together
okay like I had a lot of thoughts the
movie was not as good as I thought it
was I thought they were like really
really good things about what I thought
it was
gonna be oh okay okay I thought you
thought it was good and then you
realized it wasn't good no no I
definitely left being like oh
um but it was like still like a good
cute movie and like the message was
really cute
um there were a lot of highs you know
and lows in my opinion and it just
wasn't what I thought it would be and
overall like I actually really liked
where they took the movie but in terms
of like plot and you know like Barbie
leaves Barbie land here's why and here's
how she gets back I've was anyone else
like confused like there was just like
it wasn't clear like why she was
malfunctioning and then it was like
America
no it's really not a spoiler like for
real she's malfunctioning
like that happens in the way beginning
that's why she has to leave Barbie land
oh okay you remember like she gets the
Birkenstock or the heel no
it's in the trailer I didn't the trailer
gave away nothing
whatever she has to leave Barbie line
for a reason and then you find out the
reason and like I seriously like it was
not clear to me and like it just didn't
make a lot of like linear sense in terms
of plot okay I found myself confused and
then also like some of like the
the things like we just have to believe
because it's a movie like she's a doll
okay I just like I was confused like how
other things were happening if she was a
doll like it was just confusing
um having said that here's what I liked
about the movie it was literally
sickeningly done like it was just
beautiful The Outfits the music everyone
was just on their bed giving their best
performance and the the general you know
um
takeaway and message of the film was
very like girl boss fight the patriarchy
you know equality for women and that
like kind of cringe Millennial white
woman way which is my least favorite
type of feminism but I was able to look
past it because like you know I approve
of the message
um
and having said that I realized what I'm
about to say is extremely problematic
given that it was like a film about
women to me the best part of the film
was Ryan Gosling and I'm shocked to say
that because I was so critical of like
his casting you were
he was Stellar I've never seen him in
something funny the movie was very funny
I've never seen him in like a comedic
role and I didn't know if he was you
know if he had those chops he was
hysterical like literally all the laughs
were from him another thought I had
about the film was I'm not entirely sure
who the movie was for because there were
so many like cultural references and
like jokes that I did not get like there
was this like Matchbox 20 song I didn't
know that there was like all these jokes
and the guy behind me who was like much
older was hysterical laughing I'm like
maybe it's for an older crowd I found
myself like really not getting a lot of
the cultural pop cultury references and
Jokes which is shocking because that's
so me yeah well maybe they were trying
to do a little something for everyone
but also you are on the tail end of
being a millennial like I think the
movie is really for Millennials but that
spans like what 10 15 years and like
Matchbox 20 is a little older than older
yeah there was a lot of singing mostly
on Ryan Gosling's part which was such an
interesting creative route but I didn't
dislike it by any means the production
value was just like out of this world
there was like a bunch of like
choreographed moments like I loved that
it was really beautifully done Margot
Robbie was amazing you know Barbie's
kind of going through this you know
Journey where she like it has highs and
lows and she's crying Margot Robbie is
just like an amazing actress and Helen
Mira narrated the movie and every now
and then she would like cut in and like
acknowledge that this was a movie and it
was actually very funny like breaking
the fourth wall
um so I liked that there was a lot that
I liked about it but overall I found the
film in terms of like an actual movie
you know like plot point a point B Story
how do we get here story I found it a
little like broken and a little
confusing okay
um another major shout out to Michael
Sarah who was hysterical yeah I saw this
morning like he plays a doll named Alan
right and there's like a million Ken's
but there's only one Allen and he's like
this like Outlaw and now Alan dolls are
like going for five times the price on
eBay oh that's funny well another thing
I really liked about it was clearly they
worked you know hand in hand with Mattel
and they obviously had access to like
all these Archives of Barbies that have
been discontinued different things that
they tried and you honestly like
wouldn't believe some of the Barbies
they put out that have been discontinued
like it was so funny and Will Ferrell
plays the CEO of Mattel in the real
world and he was hysterical too like the
movie was very funny it had a lot of
heart too
um
it was good and you know my girl my girl
America Ferreira like literally love her
um she was probably my least favorite
character she has this like monologue
that's like really like the summation of
the female experience you know you want
to be a mom and then you you know you
get told that's not enough and then you
don't want to be a mom and people look
down on you and she has this like
monologue that's like an amalgamation of
Womanhood and it was giving Millennial
cringe like it was I saw like so many
people on social media being like this
made me tear up and I was like again
I was like oh I didn't tear up it was
giving like really cringe you know and
it did like it factually does
encapsulate like you know the female
experience all the things about being a
woman that are so frustrating but I
didn't find it moving I really found it
like giving like Olivia wild you know
her Story t-shirt energy you know yeah
no I understand
so
in that sense I I think maybe I'm not
like the exact demographic for the film
because I'm always talking about how
that version of like feminism is so
cringe
um but there's there's a pool for that
like there were people around me during
the monologue who were like literally
clapping they were like yes yes I'm like
okay the theater was packed oh my God
and okay
I did not know that you could reserve
seats like I assume I bought them on
Fandango like and I had to reserve my
seeds so I assumed it was those like big
plushy recliners right yeah
I got to the theater I was shook it was
like this old ass like janky ass like
there was a thousand people sitting on
top of me like I didn't know you could
reserve seats for like some [__] theater
when it's just chairs that fold down
yeah and it's like not been renovated in
30 years but it does kind of make sense
yes but we used to just raw dog it when
I was a kid yeah but now with reserve
seating like for everything it'd be
weird if you bought a movie ticket and
you didn't get to pick your seat like if
you went to buy that movie ticket and
you didn't pick your seat you would be
like did I get a ticket yeah yeah no for
sure but I thought I was going for a
luxurious experience so you know me I'm
very conscious of movie times and in an
uncomfortable chair oh my God my ass was
like starting to hurt me it was like a
really old hard chair
um I actually wasn't like counting down
the minutes which is a good sign for the
film because I'm always checking like
what time did this start it was just
like it was good like it ended when it
should have ended great
yeah it was good I obviously it just
wasn't like as amazing as I thought it
would be but it was still like a good
film with a positive message very funny
I saw a lot of discourse on the internet
being like it's a man-hating film it's
actually not there's like this whole
moment at the end where it's like Ken is
kind of this [__] who like only exists
for Barbie and they really they give him
like a powerful speech too Ryan Gosling
was hysterical see mulio was great
um it's a ray was Great America Ferrera
was good but like her character was
bothering me a lot
um who else was in it
I feel like those were the main
characters it was good it was good it
was just really there was like this
whole thing with like John Cena and Dua
Lipa who like popped in like four times
for two seconds and it was really stupid
like I could have done without that
um the music was amazing like lizzo has
this song where she's like narrating the
film but also singing a song about
what's going on as we're watching it and
it was very funny
um the music was amazing okay cool I
feel like it would be nearly impossible
for the movie to meet the hype that it's
created that's true you know which is
through only a fault of their own with
their 100 million dollar marketing
budget so the fact that it is still like
good and it's not you know a total flop
I actually think is a win
yeah that's true and it was actually
just very exciting I couldn't I mean I
was looking at theaters all over town
for tickets I had to go to the Upper
West Side it was packed oh my god there
was a five a five thirty a six a six
thirty they were all super busy there
was like a step and repeat outside
people came dressed up or taking
pictures like it was actually really
cute and fun and like just felt exciting
what did you wear
the bar sweatshirt and leggings in pink
and
so I went with my friend Margo and she
was like are you wearing pink on purpose
and I was wearing my pink the bar
sweatshirt but no I literally just
picked up one of the bar sweatshirts
because it's always so cold in movie
theaters for sure but I do feel like you
chose pink for intentionally
I swear to God I did not like it was
completely accidental I didn't even
realize I was wearing pink till she
pointed it out
look at you participating being a part
of something I was but like so
unintentionally I guess I'm just so
naturally drawn to participation
that's you
so many well thank you for going to see
it thank you for reporting back I would
say it has turdies
it has Chinese approval it's just like
keep your keep your expectations like
it's a movie you know I think it's like
larger it became this Larger than Life
thing so I don't know what I was
expecting but it's a movie you know yeah
it's not gonna be the greatest showman
you know it's not gonna change yeah no
it's not greatest showman no
um okay I also wanted to play a game
with you I could not sleep last night
because I had this song stuck in my head
this girl and Tick Tock her name is
Maddie I followed her forever she's so
funny she's British
um she created this game and it's so us
and she created this little jingle to
play before you play the game and it was
stuck in my [__] head okay all night
long when you know the words to the song
sing along
sing along so I'm gonna sing the first
word to a song and you have to guess
what the song is okay okay
let me think of something like easy
okay hold on wait I should have had a
song yeah he became so prepared let me
think of like a song that's so us
okay I got one we
I know it's one of your songs
no no it's an hour song think of it like
that and we
that's not enough I'm sorry okay so
Maddie says say give me a little more
give me a little more
what was the second word
we were we were
okay maybe I chose like a random song
are you okay
no le jins me and you maybe that was a
random song
and let me let me let me try something
else and you kind of like it started in
the middle of the sentence yeah yeah no
I [__] it up sorry okay
okay let me try one more okay
your
that was the same note
your same note as we by the way your
now I need more you're in you're in love
you're in I'm singing you're in love
true love no that's what you're insecure
don't know what for well you didn't give
me a second word you said in instead of
I can't give the whole word it's just
like a beat you try this is a horrible
game
is the intention to stump me or do you
want to be working together no I'm
trying to work with we're on the same
team okay now you're gonna give me a
song but before you do that you have to
sing the jingle when you know no but
I'll give you a song okay
you know how I feel about games like
you're not gonna get everything I know
you're literally like the least fun
person who's ever been born no I'm just
I'm serious I mean business you are
serious and it's so annoying it's
seriously annoying it's just like listen
Claudia We're not gonna like be the same
exact person sometimes we're gonna be
sticking point I do wish you would meet
me halfway on games
I'm going to give you a song I'm just
not singing Jingle that I don't know I
met you on reading I met you on Downton
Abbey and like you were right like if
you would just lean into games you'd be
like Clarity you're right no that's not
the same thing but I am meeting you
halfway because I'm playing
repeat after me when you know
no I'm sorry I can't come on okay I'll
sing it when you know the words to the
song sing along
sing along okay okay
you'd
do it again
again you'd
give me a little more you love
This Bar
has to move on okay so good team player
should we do one more like you're giving
me uh old One Direction okay I got one
okay
when you know oh my God no words to the
song sing along
okay
out
I need more
out I said I need more
I'll run in your memory so it's the same
song that I
just did you just sing that song yeah
you'd Love This Bar
oh my God
I'm really dumb like I'm not okay
well thank you for playing even though
like you took all the fun out of it no
it's fine I just you weren't being a
team player you were trying to humiliate
me I wasn't trying to stump you I was
trying to and also you are you supposed
to sing one word at a time or one
syllable
like it depends on the word like you
like
because out running out running is one
word in this song
okay that's too easy
but we're a team
yeah but like still it has to be like a
bit of a challenge according to Maddie
and where's Maddie who's Maddie and
where does she live
she's actually from the UK she's one of
my favorite creators
I'm glad that you have her
feel free to play that game with your
friends and family if your friends like
games because it's fun when you know
everybody sings the jungle it's also fun
when like people play properly
a green I'm a stickler for the roles
sure
when you know that was like literally
running through my head I could not fall
asleep till like two in the morning it
was so [__] annoying that is annoying
why couldn't you sleep
so I had like was feeling tired at like
11 30 but Ben's flight landed and he was
gonna like scheduled to be home at 12
10. I'm like okay I should wait yeah so
I kind of missed my window for sleeping
and then Ben got home and he was so
tired from his flight he passed right
out and I'm like I lost my window
waiting for you understood
so it was kind of like a disgusting
thing on Ben's party so it's Ben's fault
precisely it always is
it always is
well I'm sorry for that turdy I finished
my book last night that book that you
said that you read the perfect marriage
or yeah would you just crossed out I
didn't I actually on the whole didn't
love it okay I didn't love how it ended
like you said me neither and I thought
along the way there was just like some
really dumb [__] happening
I gave it four out of five stars because
like I enjoyed my time reading it I got
through it quick I didn't feel like I
wanted to put it down and then I took
one star away because the ending was
stupid yeah I wound up giving it three
stars too the ending like didn't scratch
the itch for me and I found it
frustrating but also like there were a
lot of weird things happening throughout
the book that I was like hopefully the
ending will explain these things and I
guess it did but not in a gratifying way
yeah oh my book club meets tonight we're
discussing happy place by Emily Henry
um hated
yeah
and I'm just like
I don't I I don't even want to say what
I want to say okay well I hope you have
fun at book club
yeah one of our members gave birth so
it's not full book club back in sash
which is okay you know obviously
childbirth is an acceptable excuse to
miss book club she's on maternity leave
from book club yeah yeah
I understand well speaking of book clubs
redheads records tomorrow so if you have
questions about this month's book we
read I could live here forever by Hannah
Halperin
email us the redheadsbookclub gmail.com
email us why not what did you just
emailed us
what have you got to lose
nothing nothing if it's a good question
like if it's even a decent question it
will likely be in the episode the bar is
low for the redheads is what you're
saying no it's not low but like we don't
get like whomped with questions I can
pretty much make room for all of them
the only time I take them out is if
throughout the episode it feels like
we've already answered this question
addressed it yeah so if it's like an
obvious question
got it well we've got a great show it's
Tuesday nothing major nothing major
those are my favorite types of episodes
lots to discuss
so watch me dance that the music was so
good in Barbie
okay I might try and see it but I also
don't see myself
actually getting there and going but I
do want to see it well if you go and see
it like make sure you're going to one of
those theaters with their your ass
you're pregnant ass will not [__] be
honest my tailbone is killing me I need
to recline of course
I actually but my theater had curly
fries
it was shocking
so uh we got at 6 30 so we were like
okay this is gonna be our dinner so we
like ate a lot we had popcorn curly
fries
um
Butterfinger and Sour Patch watermelon
and then for a nice dessert my friend
Margo had cut up an apple and brought it
from home and was actually like a great
palette cleanser and she took the skin
off
yum
yeah it was also like a cold apple from
the fridge it was like cold skinless
honey crisp apple it was so good I want
to see Barbie but I also do want like
movie theater popcorn and like movie
theater snacks that is driving force
behind if I do go see it so while the
curly fries were high the popcorn was so
incredibly stale Margaret was like when
did you get this I'm like five minutes
ago ew yeah it was really disappointing
we actually didn't need any of the
popcorn that's disappointing
curly fries on point so just stay away
from the Lincoln Center Theater
okay well for a myriad of reasons you
also said they don't recline
I feel like they probably have some it's
a huge theater it's like takes up a
whole city block I feel like they have
some audit they call themselves
auditoriums that are renovated and some
that are not and I was in like a losery
ass I should have known when I bought
the tickets on Fandango that like 19 in
this economy is not going to get you a
recliner true
I just assumed like you couldn't reserve
a seat that wasn't special I wonder if
the seats were different prices based on
the location in the theater
I don't know I had a good I also I could
have gone oh and because I thought it
was like these big ass recliners I'm
like I don't need to be that far back I
bought fifth row I'm like that's right
in the middle but because it was like
this tiny little chair I was like kind
of screening my neck yeah
and honestly I do feel like my
atmosphere marred my rating for the film
like I was uncomfortable
wow
I would see it again I feel like so much
happened it was so beautiful I couldn't
even like look at everything like there
was this one scene where she was wearing
a Chanel necklace and like it was all I
was looking at like I missed the whole
scene there was just it was like a feast
for the eyes yeah you should see it
again I know Zach really does want to
see it so
I would go again okay I'll tell him I
would okay maybe I'll join you guys but
now without further Ado here are the
fast five stories that you need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by fashion
paths we have been talking about fashion
pass for years we've been fashion past
fashion girlies for years and if there
was ever a time to sign up for fashion
pass it is now we have a million
weddings vacations plans this summer and
fashion pass is perfect for that because
you get unlimited rentals so you can
swap out your pieces as many times a
month as you want you know you're only
going to wear that wedding guest dress
once or think about all those vocation
vacation outfits that you want well
fashion pass is perfect they have all
the brands that you actually want like
good American for love and lemons beckon
Bridge show me your moo moo I have so
many pieces from Charming MooMoo and
these are pieces that retail for two to
six hundred dollars so you're really
getting an insane value when you shine
up sign up for fashion pass you
literally have so much are saving so
much money because you're not out buying
clothes all the time Jackie and I are
both on the trendsetter plan so we get
four clothing items per order and we can
switch out those items as often as we
want we don't have to wait for the like
month to pass the shipping is super fast
from Fashion pass they take care of dry
cleaning
so you just literally send it back in
the pre-labeled bag that they give you
and when you're done you get to choose
new items it couldn't be easier and the
best part is that if you find something
you really love and you want to keep
from Fashion pass you can buy it
directly from them at a huge discount
anywhere from 30 to 60 off we have a
discount code for you it is the best
discount that fashion pass offers so
you're not going to get this anywhere
else if you go to fashionpass.com toast
and use code toast at checkout you get
40 off your first month so you can try
it for literally 49 that's unlimited
rentals for just 49 with code toast at
fashionpass.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by e-boost so e-boost super fuel is
something you are going to love it is a
fabulous alternative
to energy drinks it is a super fuel it
is low in sugar it has only 10 calories
per can and it's formulated with
vitamins minerals antioxidants and
nootropics so it's not what you'd
normally expect in an energy drink and
when you compare it to like the top
energy drinks it has way less sugar way
less calories more vitamins it has no
artificial sweetener and it uses natural
caffeine for energy it's also non-GMO
it's soy free it's vegetarian it's
gluten-free they add no artificial
flavors colors or sweeteners and it's
only 15 calories or less per can so the
ingredients are really high quality they
get get caffeine from green coffee seed
and green tea so it keeps your mind and
body movement moving the 10 essential
vitamins and minerals include vitamin C
D B6 B12 zinc it has electrolytes and
antioxidants and three nootropics so
it's perfect for everyday energy late
nights if you're working or studying
before or after a workout if you're
suffering from jet lag or red eye from
your summer travel everyone gets that
three o'clock slump it's perfect for
that and if maybe you just woke up a
little hungover it's great for that too
so so the Ebu super fuel is perfect for
whatever your energy needs might be and
they are so confident that you're going
to love super fuel that they are giving
you a four pack for free all you have to
do is pay for shipping so take advantage
of this offer today and go to
ebboost.com toast to get your free four
pack of super fuel you literally have
nothing to lose pay for shipping get a
four pack it's fabulous e-boost
dispelled
e-b-o-oost.com toast and trade out those
crappy energy drinks for something
gorgeous like the e-boost super fuel
thank you Claudia
you're welcome our first story Tori
Kelly is in really serious condition
after collapsing and being rushed to the
hospital so TMZ reported yesterday that
doctors found blood clots in the
singer-songwriters legs and lungs per
the outlet at the moment they are still
working to determine if there are clots
around her heart according to TMZ she
was out for dinner with friends in
Downtown LA when she complained of
having an abnormally fast heartbeat at
one point She fainted and was out for a
while Tori's friends deliberately chose
to drive the singer to Cedar Sinai in
West Hollywood as opposed to calling an
ambulance that would have taken her to a
hospital downtown she did not want to go
to a hospital downtown and she made it
to Cedar Sinai
um and now
we are she's in really serious condition
and in the hospital
that is so scary
um so you know
CR like a risky to take to a further
hospital but I assume has better care
right um I assume I don't know the
hospital scene in LA but everybody knew
that Cedar Sinai seems to be the place
the best one and I don't know what the
dog in town hospitals are like
um so scary I really hope she's okay I'm
sure we won't like you know hear what's
going on for a while but just thank God
she made it to the hospital in a timely
fashion and
quick enough yeah
whoa whoa is Right I'd love Tori Kelly
she's a queen this is so sad yeah she's
been in and out of Consciousness during
her hospitalization TMZ says
this is just a crazy scary story yeah
I really hope she's okay like
that's all yeah
I'm Tori
Dory are you ready for our next store
like no further updates but we will I
know keep you posted but that's it for
now yeah I'm surprised we even have this
level of information as to like her
friends driving and wanting not wanting
to go to this Hospital
yeah I mean you know she collapsed in a
public place so I understand like why we
know about it but the whole detail about
the hospital I when you were reading it
and it wouldn't be insensitive I'm like
that's like weird that they know that
not that they did it and also that they
already know what the cause was that it
was blood clots in her legs and her
lungs
yeah but I feel like Cedar Sinai is like
a very um celebrity Friendly Hospital in
the sense that they have like
professional wings special yeah like
it's
I feel like I've never heard of a
celebrity who lives in L.A not being at
Cedar Sinai for birth for illness I
don't think that they have special wings
for celebrities but I think they have
protocol and like they're used to it you
know I think if you if a celebrity
showed up to a different hospital in the
country it would be like a huge deal
that doesn't happen all the time but
like at Cedar Sinai like they know what
to do they're not phased by it and like
yeah and they probably know how to deal
with like media and press and stuff yeah
yeah yeah
so thinking of Tori yeah
are you ready for our next story
I am Raven Simone claims she can tap
into energy fields to see psychic
Visions like her character on that
showroom yep that is so Raven that is so
Raven Raven is a psychic in her own
right during an episode of her podcast
the best podcast ever with Raven and
Miranda um I just want to challenge that
this is the best podcast LOL bless you
the Disney Channel Alum revealed that
she possesses the ability to see into
the future just like her beloved That's
So Raven character she said I believe it
she was such a convincing psychic yeah
it felt like she wasn't acting
yeah I mean I could just see Raven
Simone nay Baxter being in her living
room and having a vision you know oh
snap yeah
yeah she just like life imitates art art
imitates life it's so true that's that
show was you know weirdly
autobiographical her name was Raven she
was psychic it was like Miley Hannah
exactly anyway she said I believe in
psychics puns [__] intended I truly
believe I believe actually humans have
the ability in their brain to tap into
energy fields that allow for truth to
connect when you know how to translate
it correctly I can walk into a room and
it's reading energy and energy in the
psychic plane because it's not a
physical material plane
okay this is giving like Raven 2.0 like
granola energy like if Raven I think
Raven grew up in like Sacramento this is
like if Raven grew up in um like Joshua
tree so it's a different kind of energy
but I could this is like a spin-off you
know
yeah this yeah this is a spin-off but
not of the same Raven because then her
abilities have kind of like gone
backwards because she said she can't see
into the future like her character duh
but she also
she can't she can't flip it for
clarifying she can't flip to the back of
the script like her character but she
often Witnesses moments play out in her
head or gets bouts of deja vu where she
feels as though she's already lived to
the scene do you ever get deja vu
never once in my life I get deja vu all
the time okay not like every day but
like I really experienced Deja Vu a lot
yeah and it is so weird
yeah no I've I've know what the
phenomena is I've you know been with
people who are like having it never
experienced it in my life I'm like what
the [__] are you talking about I can't
even describe it really but it's just
like you'll be in a moment having a
feeling about something and you're like
I've
I felt like I've had this I've been in
this mental place before like okay well
I can like identify like an anxiety or a
feeling that I'm having and be like oh
my God I remember the last time I felt
like this like that no you know it's not
like I feel stressed and I felt stressed
last week it's like this exact
predicament like I I don't know what the
situation was
no when you have Deja Vu no
so maybe Deja Vu is just code for bad
memory no but you know me and you know
you yeah maybe you can only have Deja Vu
if you have a good memory because you're
like remembering how you feel but it
that doesn't even if you had a good
memory you would know what moment you're
remembering it's not about the moment
it's about the feeling I can't even
explain it without sounding like Raven
from Joshua Tree
talking about like you know the physical
planes yeah
now one thing about me is like I'm Gonna
Stand Raven Symone until I die like I
don't even care what she does like she
literally raised me I loved that show
more than anything it was probably up
with Hannah Montana's my top two
favorite shows on yeah Disney I love
that she like went back to it and is now
doing like an adult version Raven's home
I love this woman like I don't care what
she says I don't care what she does I
love her yeah agreed and I think this
just adds to her character and the
authenticity of the role
it's so true maybe she's like method
acting so hard
no oh yeah maybe maybe maybe that's what
this is Raven
yeah she never had to become Raven
though that's why the show was so good
it was so authentically built around her
yeah it's really true but anyways
another news she has a podcast with her
wife
I knew that her and her wife are like
big on Tick Tock and they're always
posting clips of their podcast a lot of
former Disney stars have podcasts now um
most notably Christy Carlson Romano I've
seen she is a digital creator
and hers is a little bit more
um dark I think she does a lot of
interviews and conversations about the
the really unspoken Dark Side of being
like a child actor and how the industry
exploits you and she interviews a lot of
former Disney Nickelodeon Kids now
adults who share their stories which are
not you know the good ones yeah
so she's doing the Lord's work Kristy
Carlson wow I also I saw a headline
today like I think there's already I
think there's a full house
you know rewind show with cast members
Fuller house yeah there is no no sorry
podcast
oh is there and then like Dave Collier
is now starting a podcast too like a
competing one to whatever that one is
there's also a Wizards of Waverly Place
hosted by Selena's dad in the show and
best friend Harper on the show yeah I've
seen that yeah Dave Collier is launching
a full house rewatch podcast amid the
strike I don't know if that has anything
to do with this strike
um well it definitely does by the way
but like a lot of the actors who are not
like crazy Rich yeah are need to work
but that's right the charts are about to
get oh it's gonna be like 2020 all over
again bloodbath but that's a pretty
quick turnaround one and two I actually
feel like Full House is the sort of show
that does have residuals
that's well no the thing with residuals
is yes when Full House gets played on
ABC Family that's residuals but
residuals in streaming are what they're
fighting yes no I know but they've been
having residuals on like ABC Family Nick
at night for like 30 years yeah
they're like the Friends cast yeah yeah
no that's that's fair
but they're not making what they should
I think Full House is on it's on Netflix
because of Fuller house yeah yeah
um
they're not making what they should yeah
oh here's something yeah back in the day
back in the day if you got on like one
of those shows that's why Modern Family
was such like a a crazy thing because it
was kind of the last of its time sitcoms
that got syndicated it had hundreds of
episodes a ton of viewership that's like
a ticket to Narnia yeah this is
interesting about podcasting and the
sagastra
okay members can't engage in promotion
of publicity services for work under
their TV theatrical contracts that
includes podcast appearances however
podcasts that are not produced by
companies that are part of the alliance
motion picture and television producers
are okay and given the green light which
means that Dave's Full House rewind
podcast is in the clear as it is
produced by the independent la-based
podco
wait but what does that mean for
smartless because they are produced by
wondering and Amazon is a part of the
alliance because Amazon is considered a
studio because of Prime video
let me just check have they released any
episodes yeah they keep releasing their
live episodes from the documentary they
just released David Letterman
damn those are big ones because those
are huge guests oh no they had Greta
Gerwig July 26th oh it comes out
tomorrow
for other television also obviously
doing
Steven Soderberg they are releasing
episodes the screen actually field has
to give permission for up for television
re-watch shows podcasts to proceed oh
interesting yeah well I feel like in the
next couple of weeks and months the only
things that are going to be released are
like comedy specials because those are
not Union most mostly Union projects
interesting
yeah it's a good time to be a stand-up
that's you
literally but I because I was just
looking um I saw a Jim Gaffigan posted
his new special and it's on Prime like
isn't that not allowed but then I was
reading some comments and it was like
most stand-up comedy specials are
non-union work and so Jim Gaffney is not
a member of the Union
no he is but this is a non-union project
I believe you're allowed to promote
non-union projects
if you are a union member he definitely
is because he acts and stuff
that's I'm confused
how so like that you could promote
non-union projects like the non-union
isn't standing with a union
no you you can promote non-union
projects because the whole point of the
strike is to have the Studio's feel the
burn feel the strike and Jim Jim yavagan
promoting a non-union project
um time you know what I mean yeah I
don't know I'm like they're again
admittedly so much about the strike that
I don't fully but every day we are
getting our heads around we're getting
closer we're getting closer yep
by the time the strike is over we'll
have it figured out
are you ready for our next story
little Barbie news a couple of friends
that were not
uh bo and yang Dan Levy and Ben Platt
almost played Ken's in Barbie but uh
they couldn't do it
I heard also Jonathan Groff was supposed
to play Alan oh
and honestly when I was watching the
Allen character Michael Sarah was
perfect but Jonathan Groff would have
been amazing too I love Jonathan Roth
that's funny I love almost castings the
search for the perfect Barbie and Ken
actors in Barbie fell the casting
directors who recently revealed to
Vanity Fair that bow and yang Dan Levy
and Ben Platt were all in the running to
land different roles as different
variations of Ken they were definitely
really different but they had to feel
like a cohesive group you wanted to cast
people who were really going to get on
and be great and enjoy it
um but Barbie was shot in London under
strict covid protocols which meant every
cast member was required to spend three
months in the city close to production
flying back and forth to us was not an
option that created a logistical issue
for Yang Levy and Platt all of whom did
not end up playing Ken in the film
I don't feel like any of these are like
a major missed opportunity except for
bow and yang
yeah Dan Levy would have been good too
no but like knowing what I know about
the movie and all the Ken's
um
all the Ken's
besides Ryan Gosling were really like
kind of supplemental except except a
little bit simulio was like kind of a
main character so
I don't know I just I could see Bowen
yang actually adding a lot of value yeah
I I could not see Ben the thing about
Ben Platt and this is what we were
talking about earlier he's so serious
like for what dude it's like not that
serious he would not have been able to
like chill for this movie this movie was
very chill but what if he could sing
nobody's saying except Ryan Gosling
actually there was like um by the way
and I also wanted to know if that was
Ryan Dawson's real voice because it did
sound like it was like extremely good
and then I remember he was in The Mickey
Mouse Club and La La Land
oh yeah
here's a good voice
um there was like the Matchbox Twenty
there was one singing where all
everyone's saying but mostly he was
writing Gosling singing and no I just I
can't see Ben Platt in this movie like
he really is far too serious for it I do
agree with you so while that seriousness
has like obviously gotten him really far
I think he needs to loosen up
yeah he still hasn't put out his
statement blaming the cast and crew like
I said I told you he would not release a
statement he does not play that game
he's like I don't talk to fans I don't
talk to Media unless I'm running a
project like you can all suck my dick
yeah and I think he'll be talking to the
media even less now
right
yeah
he got burned he did are you ready for
our next story
is it number four it is number four that
was quick
yeah I'm ready and four and five are
kind of like sister stories
okay but I have something to say between
four and five is that okay I oh we can
make it okay we could work with that but
they are sisters
do you want to split up the sisters
they're sisters not twins no we're not
doing the same story
for four and five
I think you should say we have to say so
that the sisters can stay together
because imagine if someone tried to
split us up
I dare them to try yeah okay these
sister stories are brought to you by
bowling Branch bowling branch makes the
softest most luxurious sheets without
any toxins or harsh chemicals they use
the finest 100 organic cotton that's
traceable from Family Farm to your
family home they have a natural
unmatched softness that gets softer with
every wash one thing about Jackson is
like we're taking bedtime seriously and
that means only the best for us and we
have been loyal bowl and Branch girlies
since the day we were born not really a
few years but it feels like since the
day we were born you should start
investing in your best sleep with Boll
and Branch who make the only sheets that
get softer with every wash they feel
buttery and breathable on night one and
they keep getting softer for years to
come yeah I've had nine for like now
that I'm thinking about it since I moved
into this apartment four years and I
haven't replaced them like they really
wash well they're still so soft
um we have the signature hemmed sheets
it's their best seller for a reason they
get softer with every wash they're made
from the highest quality 100 organic
cotton threads on Earth they feel
buttery to the touch super breathable
even in the warmer weather and they're
loved by millions of sleepers they've
also been loved by four U.S presidents
and two Peabody award-winning podcast
hosts they come in 10 different
versatile colors in all sizes so that's
twin up to California King they're made
without toxins free from synthetic
pesticides formaldehyde any other harsh
chemicals and they have the 30 night
worry-free guarantee so with free
shipping and Returns on all U.S orders
you can try it let me know what you
think and make a decision but you're
gonna like the way you sleep I guarante
I guarantee it so sleep better at night
with bowl and brand sheets get 15 off
your first order when you use promo code
toast at bowlinbranch.com that's bowling
Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast exclusions apply Seaside for
details thank you Claudia I think it was
really important that you shared that
message then I do feel like I got
something off my chest and I'm feeling
lighter than air for these sister
stories these sister stories First Love
Island Stars Molly May and Tommy Fury
are engaged I'm obsessed I don't even
watch a show I don't know who they are
I'm obsessed I don't watch the love
island in the UK either but you told me
about Molly May and Tommy Fury and now
I'm so obsessed so after four years
together they're engaged the fashion
influencer and pro boxer are both 24
announce the exciting news with this
week they're so young no I didn't
realize that with a sweet video proposal
shared via both of their Instagram
accounts uh the caption was forever with
the date and in the video Tommy is
surrounded by bouquets of flowers
holding their seven-month-old daughter
Bambi and he gets down on one knee and
passes uh Bambi to Molly and she says
yes
no it's so cute in the way like I'm
obsessed but now I mean I know and then
watch your season I would like didn't
even know he was a reality star when
that whole fight happened
but now I'm like being targeted with
content from their time on love Island
and it's like very clear from the second
they were in The Villa they were like no
drama like they were just obsessed and
they were like so funny like immediately
slid into this role of like old married
couple and like the nation was just
Obsessed the world was obsessed and now
their love story like panning out in
such a unique non-traditional but like
uniquely them kind of way like he was a
boxer and then they had a baby and now
they're gonna engage like it's so cute I
feel like they're so famous like mostly
like they're famous here but really in
the UK I think they're incredibly famous
they're kind of giving me just I know
this is going to sound crazy but I feel
like they're the next version
of Kiara ferragne and her husband like I
know it sounds crazy oh I I do like that
comparison
because they're like International but
like known everywhere she's like started
out as an influencer which is considered
you know like tacky business and Molly
May and him are like reality stars but
they're becoming like serious business
people yeah no so like he has his own
career as a boxer just like Kiara's
husband is a singer singer also I don't
know if you saw but Tommy's older
brother
is a big boxer like a really that you
told me that yeah and he got a reality
show on Netflix UK it's his family's
reality show it's like I don't know what
the name is but I'm loving this and
Tommy and Molly are in it got it and so
I just watched the trailer the other day
I wonder if it'll be available to
Netflix Us in which case I need to get
back into my account because I would 100
watch this
oh yeah and then I think during her rise
to fame she was then hired Molly May as
the creative director of pretty little
thing UK which pretty little thing is
Big here but it's huge in the UK and
that took her to like another level
she's not with them anymore but
um she they just kind of like turned
this random reality show Fame into like
astronomical thing yeah no I follow her
and I love following her just as like a
fashion girly and as a mama like she's
like just is so her content is so
wholesome and she's a beautiful life I
didn't even realize they I didn't ever
think about whether or not they were
engaged or married or whether or not
they should be so to see them get
engaged like it was just so sweet
no and he's like so hot and she's so
cute and pretty like I'm obsessed
obsessed you should watch their season I
know people say that we should people
have said that to me no the way I know
everyone's mad at us for not watching
Love Island because like everyone
there's so much crazy stuff happening
every day and we're not talking about it
then I see like other people watching it
every day I think they're up to like
episode 55 like I can't yeah no it is a
lot
I have no regrets but I do apologize to
the community of toasters who are
waiting for us to watch I will not be
watching but I might watch this maybe I
should watch the season if I find myself
with a lot of time on my hands so I do
feel like those are you saying us or UK
just the season of Molly and Tommy in
the UK oh
you know yeah I don't know if I would
waste my time again with us
well us they are doing the most for
which leads shortly than final story yep
Ariana the sister story bombshell Ariana
Maddox gives first look at love Island
USA appearance quote I can't believe it
she says so the Vanderpump Rules star
gave fans a glimpse into her guest
appearance on love Island USA on Monday
she said I can't believe I'm popping
into the Villa this week uh she posted a
photo of herself sitting at the fire pit
like I am gathered around the fire pit
you can watch the fun on peacock she is
in front of a sign that says it was
always you now what do we think she's
doing there
nothing like people I think they're
trying to make it seem like she's going
to be a contestant she's not she has
like a full ass career they're filming
right now she's got to get back and
she's not a contest
perhaps it's like a challenge or she
just comes in and gives advice like it's
just a cameo yeah
this is you know a perfect Synergy you
know Bravo's a part of the NBC Universal
Universe love Island USA is on peacock
it's just it's called Synergy people
don't be fooled it's okay but like still
she has to like feel some sort of role
when she's on the show like they're
definitely doing a challenge like and
she and you know it's perfect Synergy
because uh when Tom Sandoval and her
were fighting he was like all you do is
sit at home watch Love Island so
everyone was like yeah that's all anyone
does oh okay that's good synergy
so there's like a connection it's a
reference it was a good call by the
marketing team for peacock to use Ariana
she's kind of like a a press magnate
these days yeah well love Island USA I
think it just started again and they are
really I feel like for a few years like
they were doing love Island USA it
didn't really get like the love that it
should have or even like the support
from like the network it wasn't big
really talked about or anything and I
feel like this year they're trying
they're pulling out all the stops you
know yeah I've been seeing it everywhere
they just did a Big Brand trip right
right to the Villa with influencers so
they're finally trying they've never
competed with UK but for a lot of the
time it felt like they weren't even
trying yeah
however the season that we watched was
actually very good we watched it was at
the last season no I think there was one
last summer the one with Shannon and
Josh who are still together I'm obsessed
um
that was pretty good and people were
like that's not even close to as good as
UK like yeah that the best season of us
is not even as good as the worst season
of UK right why why can't they make it
better
honestly it's the accents I really feel
that way oh really I feel like it's
probably for a chat I feel like it has
to do with whatever networks they're on
like I think that
um maybe now that they're on peacock it
could be a little
more mature but when it was on like NBC
every night it has to you know like the
bachelor even though like The Bachelor
is kind of stupid because it's extremely
PG yeah
but like too hot to handle on Netflix
it's [__] Bonkers yeah it's like a
porno right
and they're talking about like I don't
know if maybe they the the the the level
of like sexual activity is the same on
both shows it's just a matter of what we
like see and what they talk about
um
but I don't think they could do that on
NBC which is why I think moving to
Peacock maybe it'll be a little bit more
mature yeah yeah
mature that's just my theory but I again
don't know what happens on the UK one
but maybe I'll maybe I'm about to find
out
yeah
so I'm happy for Molly may all right
Ariana yeah sister stories were they not
sisters
they were definitely related they were
Halle and Annie ones the UK one ones the
California one
they were highly not California yeah
Ariana's in California
no they don't film love Island USA in
California no no but she's the
California Girl
yeah but you love Island USA
okay
it was an amazing announcement she's the
Fiji sister no I don't know why I was
like trying to make an analogy bad when
it was clearly good I'm sorry for poking
a hole in it like that was low-key
disgusting of me just because I can't
make a good call doesn't mean I should
take down everyone else's
wow thank you for that heartfelt apology
yeah welcome
[Laughter]
so that's our show those are the fast
Side Stories feel as though you needed
to know them and what else what do you
got going on today am I going to see you
I hope to I hope to see you that would
be nice that would be nice I think we
can make it work
we can definitely make it work God
forbid to come to my house no I'll come
to you you know what I was thinking
yesterday I don't think I've been to
your house once since I've been in New
York no you haven't it's [__] road
but like how would I get there
a car I know but like what would I be
doing there
chilling okay so then I'm bringing Harry
duh so then we have to think of coming
over without him right okay so then
we're in a car I have to bring the car
seat
and I can't like carry both of those
things so like Zach's coming with me is
Ben going to be there
then it's after work no no but seriously
getting all the fun out of it right but
then it's after work and like then we're
getting close to Harry's bedtime that's
this is why I haven't come over
you know what with that attitude don't
come okay I'm just saying no it's not
there's a reason why it just like
doesn't make sense especially when you
just like like
levitate on over here if you wanted to
if you wanted to you would
I just really don't feel like that
applies
okay
okay but okay
but enjoy your victimhood
will do
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toaster Millennium Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to do every Monday through
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcasting we found Spotify
iTunes Stitcher public radio
iheartradiocastbox all the places so I
will listen to podcasts find us the
toasting the five star review about our
beautiful standing and wickedly talented
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
we'll see you tomorrow for one of the
greatest days of the week
love you bye